this video is brought to you by
expressvpn and Shopify people more on
them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
it is time for Monarch episode 7 today
ladies and gentlemen tell us tell us
tell us before we watch it did you like
this episode was it more engaging than
the others do you prefer the 50
storyline or the present day story line
leave your thoughts down below anyway
John are you good I'm so good me too man
I'm ready to Monarch on you know what
I'm saying it's a phrase the kids say
now shiver Me Timber what the all the
Kaiju audiences say yeah get my Monarch
got to get my Monarch let me put on my
Monch leave a legacy of likes would you
hey that's good monstrous
subscribe button um don't be Shaw and
support prepper for helping s down these
highlights um the Philippines full
watch
copy super sexy rejects over a patreon
page over recover show through the
highlights and watch songs included
Johnny Monarch on may we get to it
[Music]
g the aftermath Legacy of
rubble oh please be Tim let's go my man
my man my man lives I'm Ro for this guy
man you did it
man Clancy Brown's going to play him in
the
future like you see of Tim like you see
Tim what do you think D was doing out
there I don't know oh canaro was
impersonating most of the audience when
we cut to the story
line yeah man it's the most soothing
part of the
story I've never flown first class do
you think we'll be in those pods gives a
[__] about BS I do Comfort I'm sleepy
who gives a [__] about him he took one
look at us and ran away maybe he was
trying to get away from Godzilla and
left us behind to get stomped on how is
that better that's a fair point she went
to the bathroom like 40 minutes ago what
did you expect you told her to stay the
hell away from you damn man Dam [__] has
been in there for 40 minutes the
dejected and whining chemistry of them
two is what I live for when I come to
this show
this is the real drama that I experience
in my own
life oo I've never been kidnapped before
so how does this
[Laughter]
work cool I'm going to choose that was
cool I'm going to give the benefit of
the doubt that was cool I know I'm going
to use that when I'm
kidnapped look I'm sorry I told you to
go to
hell M you didn't actually go did you
she wasn't in there but I found her
passport and her
phone maybe she forgot it may are May oh
they ver to that point it's our made now
yeah uh-huh she belongs to the both of
us oh my God what a great kidnapping hey
I mean this is an upgrade from even
first
[Music]
class I don't know must have wanted that
stuff to be left there she better have
the most compelling backstory we've ever
seening session Buzz caffeine's already
been you don't know how long you've been
at it so the sun comes up pulling you
out or your mom coming down to do the
laundry here we go uh-oh we need another
bottle what the end of the second bottle
then you give your big sales pitch and
tell me how brilliant I am and how I'm
wasting my talent when I could be saving
the world the money of course money this
is by far one of the best meals but you
missed the most important part where
quite frankly girl I'm
tired two
bottles look you are brilliant and you
can work anywhere but I think the future
looks better if you create it with me
with me o that is a pitch and girl there
is a lot of money oh what are they going
to create do like money though who cares
they got money no
way
hey he walked 10 clicks awfully fast
where is she what did you do with
her I have had a very weird day maybe
you could just take it a little easy
okay where is
May about to do the face off hand what
about the deal May made with your
partner what deal what the deal the deal
man I partner and I were having some
issues we're separated okay people die
out there is that who you people are
thank
you no that is not who we are I don't
feel like you had to go to the airport
to get all this water he could have I'm
sure you passed a bunch of other places
and water at the airport's like eight
bucks a
bottle what was he doing out there
abandoning
you he he was here was he ran off he ran
off he had some machine set up and then
Godzilla woke up what what machine oh no
is that what he was doing was he trying
to wake up Godzilla no not the dinner
bell your father spent his life trying
to prevent something like G from
happening I believe he's trying to
prevent the next one he won't Dorothy's
going to fly I have seen Godzilla versus
Kong Monarch seems to be plugged in all
over the world so help us find me and
we'll help you find Sha excuse us we're
going to go talk brother sister stuff
hey what are you doing we got a this I
no but Dad they're going to want to find
Dad I don't want to find Dad we don't
even know what he was doing out there or
why he ran off I started this crazy
Quest thinking that he might be able to
explain this I don't believe it anymore
so you can go home I love their scenes
John they always bring new light to the
situation what
happened Godzilla happened actually he
was um he was here you guys weren't
looking for that you're sure kind of
hard to miss Majestic
terrifying I'm Fair the Randa kids are
here I need to help them do something
first also I might need to piggy back
some Monarch resources if Godzilla's on
the Move we need a full debrief he was
huge he
appeared had you not treated these kids
like criminals like I said then they
might have led us to Godzilla instead of
running to Shaw that's why I have to
help them help them do what oh oh wow
find their friend may huitt they they
think that we kidnapped
her we didn't do that right we didn't
kidnap her did
we what a great
delivery Tim this is Tim's show Tim is
my favorite character one SC like tell
me you really don't care what happens to
her we can take our first class tickets
can climb into our pods and go home the
attention to detail in their dialogue
how they're always bringing details from
the previous conversation into the new
conversation yeah are they going to fly
first class will there be pods Just A
variation of range too in their delivery
Outpost 88 that's
cool double
infinity damn dude that's some cool ass
sound yeah stranger things season 4 it's
the same isotopic signature as gday but
the transmission rate is really funky oh
it's you yeah from the Breaking Bad
episode not like sour milk funky or
something sour milk Funk I'm not like
trying to step on your Turf I didn't be
that as like a
racist got to
pee got to go got to go got to go right
now oh don't leave that lady with your
computer what the
hell Godzilla shut this [__] down he's
at the circuit
breaker I am the
law shut it down I am the law good
afternoon can we have your attention
please what's going on here who the hell
are
you nice coat your base is now under my
control you all may leave whenever you
want we all know where the doors are
which we will be locking down for
operational security oh cool you can go
on as if the world hasn't changed
pretending that Humanity didn't just
wake up and suddenly find itself on the
endangered species list uhhuh you can
stand with us on the right side of
History uhoh they didn't account for
someone might be in the bathroom shoot
through the
walls damn she go fast it's FS I'm at
out post 4 uh 87 88
Outpost
31 oh this is intense Our Heroes feel
malevolent dude night into snow that's a
great shot yeah
man
uh-oh wouldn't say anything for a while
you'd almost forget he was in the room
then chime in with some perspective that
would turn the whole thing on its head
he's Godzilla he miss has a trick used
to write everything down these little
pencil stubs pencils the pencils the
shavings May told me if anything
happened to her I should call her sister
can you run a search can you use the
phone get background checks on all of
you while you were in custody the
passport that she is using is fake what
her real name is not may tay Kora Jane
sarawa her name is Kora like Legend of
Kora yeah meaning to check in on you
really I've been trying to get in to see
Brenda I do have to go but call Taylor
we'll get a lunch on the books why did
you hire me blue in her hair now I
didn't expect my code to disappear down
some rabbit hole at the cybernetic neuro
interface unit which sounds cool as [__]
by the way I think we're leading to Apex
look out she's going to be key in
developing that tech for which you
signed a contract which stipulates any
undor output you produce while in our
employ is the ex exclusive property of
AET it's not your code g it's our code
there's a seat for you at the table if
you want it but that doesn't mean you
don't have to earn it everybody doesn't
get a trophy here yeah you don't get
points for participating and doing your
damn job I was at Outpost 87 monitoring
the Gamay bursts coming from Alaska and
then these people came in and took over
can you hold your phone
horizontal can we do a troubleshooting
scene
oh turn turn it around man so Colonel
what do you want to take the beer
here I got a lot of cases chip
right all of it thought so stop stop
that's it stop stop stop I want to buy a
Toyota oh my God I love Toyota they are
very reliable cars and I associate them
with the art I like I still think we
should just just tell them the truth
what if cor doesn't want them to know
the truth that she's been hiding out
using a fake name or what if she's
protecting them from something we go
barging in there and Spill the Beans
dude there's a Titan in their backyard
got to play this
cool so Follow My Lead okay guys please
let Tim Cook Walk This Way talk this
way it's okay it's okay Tim you got this
looked improvised cor was in Japan just
passing through for work I think we're
all in an online manga group heyy I a
weeb so you saw Kora in Japan yeah uh
briefly so you all live there no I'm
from Tokyo so now you're here in Seattle
looking for my sister she's rul
suspicious what kind of manga is cor
into oh it's your basic shjo stuff I
mean obviously Nako takiuchi
Moto t
you did your research my
man when was the last time she was home
2 years to the day I still think we
should tell them what happened with me
we don't know what happened with cor did
you see her face did you see the
sister's face she knows something she's
not saying she had a sister there she is
all right get in she was awfully
suspicious of them maybe she's getting
in her car follow you guys yeah they're
just going to be following each other
sneaking its own tail we' going around
circles in the same neighborhood this
entire time go faster I know where to go
you have to go faster we going to L
she's right there she's probably seen
you oh my God this ADR is keeping me on
edge oh it's like we're in the car with
them just hold stop stop stop
stop get out get out of the car yeah
dude I'm sorry we lied to you are you
with the company tell me the truth we're
her friends that is the truth we did
meet your sister in Japan she's been
traveling with us helping us solve our
own family mystery but you need to leave
our family alone sure she likes old Tech
but thinks people who collect vinal our
hopeless
posers you know she thinks a most people
are stupid like me but it didn't stop
her from helping me when I needed her a
that actually a touching ass scene yeah
we just want to make sure she's not in
trouble it's too late for that what do
you mean Trouble Follows her wherever
she goes who's the company applied
experimental Technologies all right
almost Apex I don't remember what
applied exper I don't remember what apex
apex I mean you could applied
experiment oh hey Tom Holland's on a
rampage where's my spider
[Laughter]
bsit wrong Universe what's going on I am
I got to got to go mom wondered if you
were running to puke because you were
pregnant hey what is it I need you to
get me some cash I need to take your
passport you can report it stolen next
week okay what I have to go away okay
where I have to go away I have to
disappear where where why if anyone asks
I hate
Monga a couple days ago she called she
said she might be able to come back
she'd made some kind of deal the deal
from a couple episodes ago it's crazy if
you do find her can you just let her
know that we don't don't care what
happened we just went her home dude you
should join the show yeah she's great
just just take her along just in case
she's got a reason to be here
so what now I offered you a tremendous
opportunity
money something transformative yeah I
remember like the way have we made this
content to be able to put up on YouTube
She's a free use
[Laughter]
Pioneer it's a trouble when you hire
people good at computers to work at your
computer
[Music]
company see neuro interface and that's
the thing with Sara was kidding Godzilla
versus Gods thee to Godzilla xong
Empire all of the films the
monsterverse uh
[Music]
uhuh reference
holy [__] her backstory is super
important oh no 28 Days Later damn she
went in the basement and found the evil
Secrets what you saw down there was the
future being created it's elon's
neurolink you wiped out years of
research oh whatever I'm sure Walter has
it in his couch cushions Walter whoa
you're such a disappointment ouch Walter
it is it we've connected Ed the dots
guys we got our own CCTV coming here
about 3 hours ago nice you could also
catch a lot of ghosts on those cameras
so many floating orbs how do we get in
the door are you going to do the bag
over the head thing or does monarch have
a secret rescue system wait do you have
a rescue system sort of palpa return
sort of sort of he came back somehow I
guess maybe I just get these Pages day
by day you know Mecha Godzilla's going
in the thumbnail now guys a going to
trick everyone into thinking
Mega you know as long as you put it in a
red circle nobody can complain gday oh
no gday alert gday plus however many
that is messed up we just want her to
distract the front
[Laughter]
desk oh God is that what he did he just
did he must have done a Tim oh my God
Timothy
[Music]
Tim that is my
favorite television moment of
2023 that so happy I adore this is my
favorite episode this is my favorite
episode
like so angry Tim
that was so
amazing shouldn't we go somewhere what
do you know about monsters cor I I know
what everybody else knows I know
everyone in this company is monsters why
does that matter to you you're a tech
company we're innovators imagine what we
can learn from a nervous system that
allows something as big as Godzilla to
walk that's what the cybernetic neuro
interface were up to like a mechanical
Godzilla oh so we could recreate what it
does and thinks If This Were Real
we would have had advanced warning your
friends are obviously using this as a
cover to rescue you hey you walk out of
here clean slate and even make sure you
get your back pain this is great you
report back to me everything you learn
about these Titans oh no all this time
I've been going how the hell did they
figure out the neural link to Mechanical
godzill I don't know man I didn't and
now the show is finally giving me the
answers I have
been someone must have developed a
technology for it it's crazy you can
just leave no
I I need to tell you something my name
is Kora I'm calling to say I love you
I'm going to call again for Mom's
birthday no you won't hey man it's the
best human drama episode they've done I
got to say may K is a much more
compelling character
the writing is catching up to her
performance I wish you did my name is
cor Mato and I used to work here as a
programmer until I did something that I
do not regret oh it's why I ran away and
it's why I lied to you and you and and
Tim
Tim came all this way to catch you I
know but I didn't ask you to do that I'm
sorry for k i really seriously my name
is not May are you listening to me waa
to get the hell out of
here what she even got even even our
main character got a good scene yeah
what is this show becoming I told you
man all you had to do is wait seven
episodes that's sweet seven sweet number
seven lucky seven
baby canaro got a good moment with his
sister
all this is the best modernday episode
they've done and they haven't even shown
us a monster other than those goddamn
monkeys and we have a plane to catch no
we can't because it's possible we're all
about to be buried by whatever Shaw has
planned did you think about that hey hey
I don't work for you no you don't so
stop acting like you know my business
simply because your name is Branda what
I do know is that you have a sha problem
you need to know where he's going and
what he's doing am I right it's an
interesting sound edit there and you're
proposing a solution to this Shaw
problem of mine sh okay schol teacher
thrill me thrill me Tom Atkins baby we
found our dad's map we found our dad and
we found
Godzilla you help us get May back and
we'll help you find Shaw ktim not a bad
proposal I was pissed at you but I was
pissed at myself the night that I broke
into the lab I couldn't handle that so I
screwed us both over to so this is the
moral of your story
then yep there's an Natalia berdugo from
Monarch here asking to see you let's
go for one
more
cor
hey oh my God they Sol it off screen
what's Monarch going to say about the
Titan alert PR will handle it meanwhile
we need to get to Washington and
coordinate with the dod to get Shaw
contained Ashley hair is on fire right
now I think that we we should do this
you should do this the the pr thing
you've always been great on
camera we have to bring Monarch Out of
the Shadows
oh this was a test of the emergency
broadcast system we are monarch we are
about to go help Monarch monarch made a
deal for my freedom with a corporation
we shouldn't trust so we trust Monarch
now we're not in the clear yet I'm going
with you guys you just got back what
about your family now I can call them
anytime sweet hell yeah okay we're Al in
three damn two
one
hi I'm speaking to you today as a
representative oh my
God the utmost
power dedicated to the study of massive
unidentified terrestrial organisms or
mutos including the creature we know
as Godzilla damn she made mut sound
s or mutos we bring the best minds and
the most Cutting Edge technology
including the early warning system that
was triggered in Seattle yesterday this
time it was just a for alarm what a
great introduction we messed up listen
sorry let me tell you as a mother I
share your fear but this is not the
world we live in monsters are an
inescapable reality Secret Love constant
threat one Rand to the neck
we must learn to
survive oh no and I believe it's a very
interesting love triangle be a thle I
think if she sticks to our agreement it
could be very fruitful but oh
yes it just arrived what what is it the
spill the Myster neur link thingy I
think it's perfect a bold statement for
A's new corporate Mission Pacific Rim
good night Mr Simmons hey
Apex yeah
Apex applied
experimental Hollow Earth let's go we
need to get to the hollow Earth my
Alexander scars guard
brush we need
Kong super generic voice to Greg this
hey man he's got to work past his
natural accent you
know oh man
[Music]
all right let's bring the roof down on
these things once and for all that dude
runs in the snow smoothly damn dog maybe
Shaw is going to become a Secret villain
all right here we
go we got to work in unison with our
Titan underlords I think he's trying to
free
it I hope
so
yeah Outer Circle
Mark waa
W beautiful shot now watch
this
[Music]
wooask in the sky beam what's happening
can't tell if he's sealing or laying all
that yeah he said bring the roof down on
their heads I don't know is he trying to
close the hollow
Earth yes
[Music]
oh I don't
know I think he sealed them in because
they need to get to the hollow Earth in
godzill versus Kong to to that way they
can
complete something science fiction mumbo
jumbo
about uh that way they can use Mecca
Godzilla that's why they sent Alexander
scar Gard in there with their fun Little
Ships yeah that's right their little
Watchman ships yeah see I did my
research hey ending explained it's good
and I'm sure they did their research to
figure out what the accurate scientific
methods would
be here's a word from our
sponsors thank you to Shopify for
sponsoring which is what we use for our
merch store and is our gamechanging
partner in e-commerce whether you're
launching a passion project or scaling
to new heights Shopify is e-commerce
Powerhouse guing you at every step from
creating your first online store to
opening physical locations Shopify makes
it seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and in store sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on our journey
using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us owers 10%
of us e-commerce backing businesses big
and small and over 175 countries there
are war-winning support always there to
guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com rejects
all lcase shopify.com rejects start your
Shopify success story now let's go grow
together with Shopify team big thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a
real game changer I've been using for
years that's right years so whenever
they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum shutting
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over a 100 countries like a global
Cinema your fingertips it's super easy
open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it
whether it's kramas on South Korean
Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube or
more expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com reject so head to
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again all right guys well I think I
made my thoughts very clear on that one
it was an absolute delight and there
wasn't even monsters in it except for
like a brief flash of one so this will
easily be our lowest performing Monarch
video but that's a shame because I
really like this one I did too I really
like like this is this is the Dr human
drama show I could actually watch
yeah compared to whatever we've been
watching prior that I have not
personally been in love with that I have
been really trying to be in love with
but I thought it had a good balance of
mystery character sto isms and then and
um but but just like it actually had
like drama and personality sure you know
like there was some fun to be had it it
I'm specifically pertaining to the
modern day story I I saw the even the
top comment on like our last reaction
like I'm so much more invested in the
50s story and yes in terms of like a
truly intriguing mysterious one with all
around like dramatic Intrigue of
characters the 50 storyline certainly
wins but this one like Kurt Russell Shaw
like what is he up to he felt malevolent
and and their plan that we thought has
been nothing but benevolent and
everything with May was like man this
backstory better be freaking interesting
and it was yes it actually led to
something interesting yes it did it
wasn't just like here's her character
you know like it was actually
interesting yeah she's important to the
Future it had the cheese what I loved
about uh purple dress lady what I loved
about her performance was it was so
hammy it was so no no no yeah the boss
the new boss no no yet I'm not Natalia
vugo I'm talking about Cor how do they
how do how do
people have that native tongue do that
right into sounds so American and next
just say their name and it's just like
whoa what' you do you just turned me on
yeah how'd you do it well you by turning
your voice on you have turned me on
natur that innate understanding of how
the word is meant to be
said very true they're not just putting
on an accent yes to to Pander to people
it's just oh I know how this word breaks
but yeah no purple AE T lady yeah what I
liked about her performance was that it
felt like she would be main managerial
assistant to Damen bashir's character
and Godzilla versus K the Creator head
of Apex cuz he is so over the toop and
so mustache twirling yes and so I
thought her performance complemented
that well you you know I think that's a
really good point and I feel like I
should get credit for that I feel like
everyone dude I wish I made that point I
feel people in the comments should
comment about like wow Greg you know
you're I don't think a lot of other
people are going to point that out but
you pointed that out and I think that's
that's why we're subscribed to real
rejects you drew a connection beyond the
obvious Easter egg exactly yeah
exactly breakdown the add anything I
think if we just say it I can jusy it in
the description Bo yeah
theories every clue commentary watch
along uh yeah I thought they were great
uh I still constantly what is her name
which one the main girl Kate God damn
it's such an easy name and I can never
remember it that's the tricky part about
an easy name Kate and
canaro yes still hate their scenes
together it's never going to
change I don't like the writing around
these characters it is Bland and
repe I I understand the the rift in the
beginning of the first episode like who
are you stranger what are you saying
about my dad huh like I understand that
but uh yeah I I hate their scenes like
when it's just when it's just when it's
only them that's what I'm trying to say
Dre cuz it showed me I think what this
what this really made crystal clear for
me yes cuz it was like two episodes ago
we were like wow it really solidified
they're
boring and and and I I would have lumped
May's character into that cat or cor
whatever we want to call her yes either
is f she's so much more interesting to
me now uhhuh even when they went back
and did the whole thing of like the
conversation she was having before she
met
canaro that made me go oh okay you know
like it's not like a big freaking reveal
to me or something but it has showed me
that on a rewatch which I will probably
never do it it
recontextualized I will for the both of
us yeah it showed me that oh I imagine
on a rewatch recontextualizing it yeah
yeah yeah little it would actually make
her more her character more interesting
from the get-go yeah it's a nice moment
of proximity yeah definitely uh so feels
kind of alive actually thumbs up to that
def yeah exactly that's my point yeah it
does like this this episode felt alive
and and it and it also still gave the
connections to the bigger films in in
ways that were that's the only reason I
like any of
this nostalgia called a thing and it
came true on yeah cuz I love
interconnected universes um yeah
antecedants connecting to other
antecedants is my favorite part of the
Cinematic experience yeah I like to be
rewarded for knowing DET for knowing and
being like I think this is the thing I
think I has become reality for me which
you know as silly as we're speaking
right now it is a nice part of things
but it's also Yeah well yeah know uh go
go with K and canaro like they had
moments in this
show that were not them two talking to
each other's faces that were that I was
like oh that was a good moment yes each
of them with other characters got a good
moment now I'll tell you I'll tell you
what well no no you're not about to drop
some kind of CR criticism on me are you
I am a critique after all this Goodwill
I am going to drop a critique all right
fine go for it it's your funeral where
the hell did this Kate and may [__] come
from the need to do something like that
in the the stage in the game I had no
structure dictates idea I I the second
they addressed the idea it wasn't until
Kade is a queer character you thought
that's what they were doing I thought in
the well but I didn't see that between
them in the back of my mind I'm just
like I can imagine it because I can
imagine May if I may be so presumptuous
I can imagine May being a character who
is maybe uh bisexual or pansexual or or
queer in some way even though she's had
her experience with canaro whatever woke
yes it's to woke G and this is the exact
moment I I'm all for people of color
homosexual men
transgenders whatever but lesbians no
that is a get out of my sight sin but
man do I like to to watch them I'm a
1950s actually no 1950s American hate
all that
1950 uh yeah uh yeah that was something
that I kind of cynically in the back of
my mind was like I bet they'll try or I
won't be at all surprised if they try
cuz I'm like no wonder Kate's like I got
to save her as I love her
apparently I really enjoyed this episode
to and I I liked The Human
Experience it presented much more than
any other episode on this part of the
timeline for sure uh that is something
that is a
choice like I'll always take a
progressive Choice regard even if it's
not very inspired or whatever I'd rather
have it than the same old thing but it
is like kind of broad to me in a way
where I'm like of course I guess like
it's weird there is nothing about the
characterization the characterization is
just so weird I thought this episode
worked nicely because it smartly at
least to me as a viewer
repositioned just the proportionality of
how all the characters are presented so
like having Tim kind of be a driving
force of this epod I really want to save
Tim for its whole other category yeah we
don't have to talk about him now I'm
only I'm only why haven't brought him
up remixing the focus so that our lead
characters feel a bit more like
supporting characters I think was a
smart choice because it allows for them
not to really improve the writing of
those characters but it makes the
experience like okay that their scenes
are like that and then yes like the my
problem with Kate is that I feel like
the show has done such a weird
job
tonally drawing her story
so like I never feel
like I don't know I liked her scenes
especially with may but part of me is
like I can feel them doing this and I
don't I I know logically where it's
coming from but it doesn't feel like a
thing the story has been focused on or
earning at all so it
is it's there's still a disjointed
detachedness where I'm like I like this
actor but out of everybody it's like the
three of them have always felt like
they're all in a different thing and
kiry Clemens is in like the best thing
of the three of them except it's taken
until now to like have enough context to
be like oh I get why you are the way you
are and why your demeanor as a character
is the way it is and now I can see past
the way that's kind of abrasive and and
you know grading when all three of them
are like forious reasons no I'm AR there
with you uh and you know can
canaro I I go back and forth on like
he's the chillest presence there's a way
that K oscillates between when she's
like super pey and when she's like
angsty that never quite feels like it's
the same character to me I I can't tell
who this character is I just know
there's an actress here doing a fine job
I still don't think that like she's a
bad actor or anything or or or I just
it's yeah the the
the I she had the most moments this
episode that I enjoyed but I still don't
feel like I am actually seeing a
character here I feel like their brother
and sister for sure their brother and S
like May Kora feels like a character and
kataro kind of feels like a character
he's just kind of a one note character
and then Kate is is sort of all sorts of
things and I felt like I had a much
better grip at least on who she was
before and now they're gallivanting
around the world and there have been K
more Kaiju attacks and I I feel like
this just doesn't feel like the same
person with the trauma as she was like
two episodes ago uh I liked her scene
when she met up with May and was like
come on May let's go let's go on an
adventure let's leave may come on she's
like no Kate your character doesn't make
any sense it doesn't it doesn't listen
to me you got to go and like but but
may I love
you yeah shut up Kate you were nice to
me once you were nice to me once in a
cave and now we're in love we've had no
scenes together to build our
relationship except I don't understand
why you care about me so much except
that one time where you just did the
like decent human thing of not just
completely ignoring me while I was in a
moment of Crisis but may we can assume
the audience has had a we've had we've
had a lot of offscreen conversations
what other women on the show are you
going to be in love
with flashback girls not in the picture
anymore there no other logical choices
um which I love to to bring it back
around I love the choice even though I I
kind of I I I genuinely am happy how we
got here it's an i i ironically love
this choice I was listening to it going
this show would be so much more
interesting if they if they just had
made their Dynam if they really made the
interaction and the dynamic like oh [__]
I think something's going to happen
between Kate and me and and then canaro
I'm like oh if they just played into the
love triangle love it all history
freaking repeating itself think of it
and then him being like oh you already
got one of my families now you're trying
to steal way a whole other family for me
with may I could could have made some
actual interpersonal drama then people
would be complaining about like I show
up for a monster show not a love
triangle show but I'm like at least a
love triangle drama would be more
interesting than whatever than this
freaking land [__] we've gotten before
with these guys there is so much anyway
and I likeo looks away and is kind of
Charmed by it as much as like they've
had their stuff like I that was the
first time the three of them all felt
like a unit ever butaro is the one who
is able to talk to the sister and be
like here's who may really is but you
know who couldn't do that Kate Kate cuz
Kate don't know this woman no no no I'm
homophobic but kentaro is going to get
with the sister and then may and uh Kate
yeah sounds age appropriate yeah
she's driving she must be probably at
least 18 one would imagine May sister
especially I want to become an American
citizen come live with me in
Japan come come to my art gallery open I
don't want to go to what did I just say
sorry what joke did I say and then what
joke did you make John sorry what did I
say you said that he he would have to
you know marry her I said be I want want
to be an American citizen and then what
did you say Oh I thought you said I
don't want to be an American citizen
sorry oh see this thought you said I
don't want to be an American
clarification of communication
enunciation it's a really important part
of communication is a lot of times it's
just a common misunderstanding and it's
true he thought her one thing and I got
vexed to the court
vexa anyway let's talk about Tim Tim's
like the savior of this show Tim Tim is
do you is he's caring the show on his
back Tim is Kevin Wyatt Russell and and
uh and the doctor his
energy is what I crave from this show
we're like when it's serious I take it
seriously with what he has to say he
provides World building he provides
Intrigue into the conversation he's
funny he to be funny yeah like every
quality that I liked about about this
episode Tim is emblematic of all of that
you know yeah cuz it he's layered he's
the only multi-layered personality of
the entire show like he's F he's he I'm
telling you like it's not just cuz oh he
made me laugh like he can be he's
sincere too he can be dramatic and I
take it I'm like I'm really paying
attention to when he's getting intense
and he feels like the exact right tone
to fit what the world out cuz he's an
old white man and I've been programmed
by the creation of Television to to pay
attention I'll add to that he's giving
me the Vibes that I was kind of hoping
for from other old white man uh Kurt
Russell I like Kurt Russell but thus far
in the show Kurt Russell has mostly been
here to to mainly be Kurt Russell you
know yeah I like Kurt Russell cuz I like
Kurt Russell yeah whereas like he's not
bringing like that extra ounce of like
this is a magical character ofic World
Kurt Russell's being Kurt Russell and
why Russell's playing a character I know
the weirdest part to me and and again I
don't necessarily blame Kur Russ they
haven't written anything in they've only
written functional things for him in the
present timeline since we left his
little compound well they don't know
Wyatt Russell's voice they were like we
can't just write it to sound like her
Russell because maybe Wyatt's going to
get upset about that yeah W like I'm
still trying to form my own identity he
make me be my dad well being my dad's
Shadow and I mean I how there's such an
opportunity there for to show the
passage of time and make Kurt Russell a
bit more of a Kookie or or a character
that makes you ask how did that guy in
the past kind of become this guy I can
kind of see it but there's some stuff I
would love to know more about I thought
he was so much more intriguing even
though he had less lines yeah him
breaking in giving the choice the very
threatening Choice yeah to the employees
at monarch of like let's do something
good even though sounds dangerous yeah
there's an an irony to when he was
cheering at the very end you're not
really sure what he's up
to I I thought this was the most
intriguing he's ever been even though he
had less screen time yeah um L scenes
about like to me this is when I really
felt like oh this is a real this is
becoming like not just Kurt Russell
being Kurt Russell yeah it's part of the
more interesting aspect of the show
because you have Monarch and everybody
else kind of in Monarch's way and the
interplay of like well you've got this
person from Monarch who is kind of like
disavowed Monarch and is going rogue and
and is going to team up with Kurt
Russell but then maybe they think
they're doing a good thing and he's
actually GNA be doing something that's
maybe kind of villainous or something
but can we trust Monarch but now we got
ape like those things those like
entanglements I think are actually kind
of nice they they help out and I agree
like his presence here again I still
think it's functional It's like because
we're now watching him go villain that
makes me think of the old plot line of
like okay well up till now we've seen
some of the seeds of where this Trio
could go wrong in the past um especially
you know with the tension back and forth
of like well we got to keep the Army
happy but we got to look after these
creatures and stuff and I'm like okay
maybe this will hearken to something
we're about to learn in the past
about him going off in a more uh you
know Iron fisted direction or something
like that uh or uh what am I trying to
say iron claw I don't know you know
something that's like Hardline something
that's a bit more milis that's right yes
uh yeah maybe maybe this will kind of
foreshadow his past turn toward the more
militaristic the more you know like if
there's even a 1% chance kind of mindset
you know either way I like to have I
shot everything in my life like that but
but I'm going to cover this movie even
great all numbers are pointed it's going
to fail if there's even a 1% chance
it'll do well on YouTube I'm going to do
it we got to kill we got to kill these
kiju if there's a 1% chance I'm
uploading 40 videos a day all off of a
1% chance that tell
Tu hey you know you'll have a couple
hits in there odds are but Tim has that
flavor of character that I would have
hoped for from a Kurt Russell because I
think it's fun when he does show up and
act and bring you know it's that thing
if you want some of that innate Kurt
russellin because that's part of what we
love about him he is one of our
remaining movie stars uh of yester year
uh and yeah I've been so excited for him
and I'm like yeah Wyatt Russell is the
more interesting presence but he's doing
more of the dramatic stuff so on the
current timeline I'm like I want to have
some fun with Kurt Russell and I feel
like Tim represents all of the flavors I
kind of would hope for from him yeah uh
no I I loved him and that moment when uh
go uh trying to mumble my way through it
and with a with a really really good
Spanish accent I got to say him I did
um which she is fuming in the helicopter
is the helicopter a
car like it such like a I think she's
flying at like the shot just went on for
so long of her fuming and and it such
like a fuming so where every part of her
face s of switch and
I
Tim knew was Tim so f it was so funny
that was that was my favorite moment of
this entire show and that's the kind of
cheese I I I do appreciate I love the
cheese of that moment I have to imagine
they knew that this was going to be a
little
cheeky cuz it's
freaking like there's so much music and
intensity and then it goes was quiet at
that moment that was perfect such an
innocent Plucky name
Tim Yeah Yeah Tim Tim VP oh that was
that was genius yeah agree genius and we
got a split second of monster action
yeah that was a great shot um that was a
great
shot and some solid enough for Apple TV
to put that on their social media
commercial God that we get blink for
then spoiling on our thumbnail when I'm
like but I saw it on an ad we see what
you're doing Apple someone was like wow
thanks for spoiling Godzilla in this
episode in the last one I was like you
mean the the sold like that was that was
the entire commercial for this episode
that I saw on my
Twitter is that the scene was going to
happen that seems to be what they want
me to take away from watch they want you
guys to know least that's what they want
me to expect from this episode like they
know to know he's in this you're getting
mad at me they're banking on you being
excited that he's in this and coming to
check it
out yeah um oh well that's my rule of
thumb I'm like if it's in the trailer
that's your rule of
thumb nailed it Legacy of jokes Legacy
of
Comedy uh yeah
when when that's my that's my rule it's
a good rule it's in the trailer
especially if it's in the commercial
that's when I was like a TV commercial
mhm or if a much much much bigger
channel has already done
it where I'm like yeah it's we
definitely have similar audiences there
they got like hundreds of thousands more
views than us right now so so people
can't be that
enraged yeah because I'm just a follower
like all you guys hey everyone's
following everybody else it's an or or
or if a really small channel does it
then I then I do it it's just to show my
support for a small Channel yeah I want
to lift them up by you know showing
their spoilery or if there's a Channel
with an equal number of views I do it
because I'm competing with them because
I want to take them down yeah so bottom
line I just don't hold myself
accountable I'm going to look at you
shouldn't have to either they have more
subscribers and Views already so why not
less views I'm going to show my support
throw my hat in the ring equal views I'm
competing and there the only way to find
out who's really on top by having the
same image so
well yeah what I'm going to do it John
yeah I'm taking notes man or learn the
ways or the company who is producing the
show has already spoiled it themselves
via extensive marketing it's like I
remember literally paid money to spoil
this for you I remember on gen V the all
the social medias for Gen V were showing
were put a promo photo of Jensen Ackles
sure out of of uh Soldier Boy returns
this episode sure so what I did in the
thumbnail was I used that promo image
that's not in the
episode yeah if people were like can't
believe you spoiled it told your voice
I'm like this is
literally from not even the episode this
is from advertising they paid for from
gen V social media saying he's going to
return this week this is what they want
to entice you with I know it's a whole
discussion that people want to have and
yell at me for I've EXP my reasoning got
to have it hey you know it makes sense
to me just just spoil everything you
know oh and Views and Views
get does because then people are like
either way it's either I got to see that
or I got to open the video and comment
my dismay yeah yeah yeah view either way
yeah g know view either
way going out of your way to get that
view get that
spoiler
and then you know sometimes certain time
passes and you're like ah I'm going to
put this photo thumb up how much time I
like five to seven minutes seven
minutes Fair most our reviews don't come
from notification Bells no they come
from when you change the
thumbnail to a spoiler
thumbnail they all start to Pile in why
is this only got like 10 views oh wait
wrong yeah yeah most our reviews come
from YouTube recommendations it's true
or search actually no search
search the thing that surprised me the
most because come from
search like most of
our or any of most of the shows or mov
like the movies recommendations sure the
shows and trailers sech search so you
got to want to see so you yeah that
that's the part that shocks me the most
I'm like it shows here vast majority of
VI yeah are for people typing in people
seeking this
out well then you've got no one to blame
but yourself must one person there's
that those few people though where some
do come from recommendation it's fair it
is fair you know fair but you can't
guarantee 100% to that point I muted and
blocked all things up Barbie oh yeah and
scream six for many months yeah cuz I
knew we were going to react to it here
and I managed to avoid all spoilers and
you best bet this YouTube channel be
subscribed and have a lot of
notification bells for many a channel
yeah and Bam still manage to avoid all
spoilers well done dude a genius you
should publish like a course for people
to follow so yeah 10-step program to
avoid getting any and all details w a
book have chat jbt WR it bestseller
change just a word uh every sentence one
word just uploaded a little contract be
like here's an NDA for you to be my
Ghost Rider can you sign this m and you
know chat gbt doesn't you're like I'll
see you in court if you can discern in
the last 10 minutes here what was
serious and what was a joke and uh hey
thanks for being here we'll talk to you
all soon what you think this episode of
Monarch Justice for
Tim all right John pick a name alrighty
let's do David Gandy David Gandy do you
know what you're getting for Christmas
this year David
Gandy I am going to go to Arizona
find a
cactus chop it down for
you and leave it directly in on your
front door this giant Cactus and you
will have the honor yourself yeah of
having a move it wherever you find fit
you can propagate it if you want to just
right there on your
porch on wet
cement
it's just a part of the porch now if you
don't act fast so either you move it or
every single day you got to maneuver
your way around it yes really the choice
is yours and this is a test of your
tenacity on how quickly am I willing to
tackle a an objective of my to-do list
that day or am I going to procrastinate
and go maybe I can wait till tomorrow
but then you wait till tomorrow and man
tries before you know it you got a
disgusting decaying Cactus right on your
front door man so I hope you enjoy it
but really the cactus is is to teach you
a lesson it's about
patience well or what how does that or
to not make powerful
enemies or uh they'll be don't be
prickly at at Christmas time it's more
about just getting something done and
moving Cactus hey take initiative Dave
go move the cactus your porch is a
walkway people need to use that yeah
man but seriously I'm going to get you a
cactus get ready clear space on your
mantel piece David but no man I know
you're like probably performing guitar
at your church yeah taking some cool
singing for everyone taking some cool
pics of everyone at church while you're
playing guitar with your action figures
your action figures and telling them
about old movies yeah because I know you
David I know you man you don't change
you don't change you're the same
stubborn Republican we've known our
entire lives what they call you at the
patreon the stubborn Republican stubborn
Republican
Gandy doesn't stop preaching preaching
is Val grand old Gandy it's like gosh
man look I can be friends with a
republican but dude you got to stop
shoving your opinions down my throat
David I got [__] to do
buddy uh but we love love you man and I
hope you enjoy the cacti and I really
want you to know that Jesus loves you he
does he told us God on the other
hand he's got a conversation he's that
with you yeah but Jesus he's constantly
just being like Yo dude my dad's about
to show up you might want to duck out
and David's always like duck out the
back why that did I do something like
hey man I'll explain later dude we'll
talk about later I'll shoot you with
text and then I'll send you the Holy
Spirit holy spirit will contact you man
and why can't you just tell me now
should I just talk to him he's like how
urgent should I be the last thing you
want to do is talk to he'll Smite you
right now he talking don't even sign the
cross don't let him cat you praying
right now you got to just lay low for a
while yeah don't go to church don't go
to church he's going to know if you open
the Bibles just like you know whatever
you do hide hide hide from God and
that's the name of your your biopic name
of your movie hide from God hide from
God damn that's that's badass that's
hardcore it' be a scary movie it would
be hiding from God yeah how you do it
God's hunting you down it' be a 30
second
movie but that's clever R depends yeah
what's the rules well the first 90
minutes are backstory yes why God is mad
at David and the last five the last five
minutes is when he comes and gets yeah
the last
then the remaining after the five or
just him having a conversation yeah be
like hey you didn't need to go to all
this effort I'm not that mad I still
love you yeah just could you get some
[__] my whole point is I I forgive you
I'm just disappointed you know anyway
David Merry Christmas buddy mer
Christmas we have a joyous
[Music]
one